est-ce que ce qui s'est passé est ce que
cette tragédie chance quelque chose à
cette poésie new yorkaise qu'on voit
beaucoup dans vos livres aussi à vous
change quelque chose à cette poésie des
demi heure et a mis beaucoup vos livres
elle est beaucoup trop tôt de parler de
ce mec futur maintenant pour moi de
toute façon mais la ville tels que maire
il s'en fait est ce qu'elle est
maintenant non je ne crois pas et je
crois que une ex esprit extraordinaire
et surgit d'un de cette tragédie
à new york aussi la réaction des gens
exactement le soutien donc on donne le
la générosité la solidarité des gens à
je crois montrer quelque chose qui était
toujours là à new york mais on le voit
rarement
et c'est une ville avec beaucoup de vous
sur semaine et je crois rien n'est
changé en permanence mais c'est une
grande tragédie qui va vite devenir une
partie de notre histoire
est-ce qu'il faut reconstruire les twin
towers je ne sais pas je crois pas moi
je préfèrerais avoir une morale là et
peut-être avec un les détours un
minuscule et un terrain vide mais qui
sait on a besoin d ailleurs bureaux à
new york aussi et c'est une grande des
spas ce qu'on gérera merci pour le site
est en tout cas depuis plusieurs jours
on voit des incidents pas spécialement à
new york mais partout dans les états
unis contre la communauté musulmane
alors qu'en dit elle comment réagit-elle
c'est un reportage d'isabelle bechler et
de tristan le braz un mot paul auster
vous pensez qu'il ya un risque que des
communautés s'affrontent les unes contre
les autres à cette occasion ce sera une
plus grande tragédie et j'espère avec
tout mon coeur que ça ne se passe pas